hello readers I suppose it's time if we
have two to talk about tone you see if I
were feeling snide or dismissive or
sarcastic I use a lot of disdainful
language to talk about how little I
valued this topic which is a piddling
trifle a Bagatelle a trivial little
nothing far more likely though
considering my love of language is the
notion that I'd be enthusiastic and
encouraging I would say understanding
tone unlocks a treasure-house of
understanding it is a feast of knowledge
tone communicates how an author feels
about the topic they're writing about
this can come across in a number of
different ways it can reflect their
enthusiasm or skepticism it can also
communicate formality or informality an
academic paper or a speech before the UN
for example are very different things
from a toast at a wedding or a thank-you
card for a birthday gift and this kind
of difference in tone is something that
sociologists and linguists call register
social conventions and customs call for
different registers in different
circumstances just as it would be
inappropriate in most situations to wear
a tuxedo at the beach so too would it be
incongruous to use extremely formal
language in an informal setting dear
honored sir
it was the privilege of my very life to
have you attend my 14th birthday party
I am grateful beyond words for your most
generous gift a cheque for 36 American
dollars your humble and obedient servant
David in fact using extremely formal
language and high-minded gratitude for
something as relatively small as a
birthday gift might even come across as
sarcastic or insulting but this is sort
of an extreme example let's pull back
and discuss how an understanding of tone
can aid you in making sense of
informational texts one great way to do
that is to analyze word choice we can
look at a writer's language and
determine their attitude towards the
subject based on the words they've
chosen to describe it
oceans of ink have been spilled over
comparisons between a chicago-style hot
dog and a New York style hot dog
the first with its gardens worth of
toppings but a holier-than-thou
prohibition of ketchup the latter with
its sauerkraut mustard and dubious dirty
water cooking style but scant attention
a droplet of ink before the ocean has
been paid to the half-smoked the unsung
but mighty regional sausage of
Washington DC now how does the author
think about the subject well we know
that they think that not enough writing
has been done about DC's regional
sausage the half-smoked but how do they
feel about it how do the words they use
express their feelings let's break it
down bit by bit so right out of the gate
we have oceans of ink this is a
deliberate piece of overstatement there
are no literal oceans made of ink but
it's being set up in opposition to the
droplet of ink used to describe half
smokes later in the paragraph half
smokes are described as unsung but
mighty which suggests that they haven't
been given their due there hasn't been
enough praise for half smokes and that
therefore the amount of attention given
to Chicago and New York hotdogs is
unfair or even disproportionate I think
we can also determine from word choice
that the author thinks a Chicago hot dog
is a little ridiculous and that a New
York hotdog is a little gross how do we
know this Chicagoans generally don't
like ketchup on the hotdogs and the way
the author phrases this is by saying
that they have a holier-than-thou
prohibition on ketchup which is to say
they get all haughty and upset about it
which is weird because it's ketchup
listen I'm a Chicago win by birth I used
to feel this way and I'm not even sure
why similarly the word dubious in the
description of the New York hotdog
meaning doubtful suggests that the dirty
water cooking method is kinda nasty
sounding why would the author do this is
it to say these are terrible hotdogs and
nobody should eat them no I don't think
so the author is trying to make room for
the half-smoked in the National sausage
conversation and to do that they're
first trying to dismantle the importance
of New York and Chicago style by making
fun of them
these are tactical choices not to be
confused with authorial voice which is a
different concept entirely an author's
voice is their style it's much more
consistent across topics whereas a tone
is
think to a topic so I might have an
authorial voice that uses a lot of goofy
wordplay but I use a sympathetic tone to
talk about bears and a hostile tone to
talk about I don't know
whales yeah boo whales I said it I do
not actually hate whales I love whales
but my point is this use your knowledge
of words of the connotation and
implications of the language that an
author might use to unlock your
understanding of their tone because if
you can do that my friend you can learn
anything Dave it out